hey a doc you seem like an utterly
logical person and i'm sorry to even be
asking you this question since it might
upset your viewer base should you answer
you've peaked my curiosity
before we start i gotta say whoa
sells at work you guys absolutely
bombarded my comment section requesting
that i watch cells at work i'm
so curious what is it about the show
that you like cause i haven't seen it is
it that it's anime
and you're huge anime fans is it a
unique way to talk about medicine that
you really enjoy
please just jump down into my comment
section let me know why you love
cells at work and i promise i will get
to it i will review it now
let's respond to some comments
are you religious and can you be a
medical professional and also
a devout christian wow heavy question um
i grew up pretty much without religion
neither of my parents
are or were religious i don't really
celebrate any religious holidays
i grew up in an area surrounded by all
sorts of religions because i grew up in
brooklyn but i
never saw myself as a religious person
not for any bad reasons but just because
it wasn't part of my life that being
said i think
you could be a religious doctor as long
as you're not
doing anyone any harm with your own
religion
practice whatever religion you want to i
think that's the beauty of living in the
united states does reading and bad
lighting have a negative effect on the
eyes
mari it does actually because you
actually
have to constrict your eyes and make the
muscles of your eyes work a little bit
harder
to concentrate on what you're reading in
poor lighting and that sort of fatigue
is not good on your eyes
something else i want to throw in here
looking a lot
at the specific wavelength of light
that's in our phones and computers the
blue wavelength of light
can actually contribute to a condition
called macular degeneration
we've seen some early research on this
nothing
that completely proves cause and effect
beyond a reasonable doubt but
it's enough that i should tell viewers
if you can limit some of your exposure
to blue wavelength like you should
probably do it
when should a girl start going to the ob
gyn that's actually a really good
question
abby what i want to really tell you
about this first and foremost is that
you don't necessarily have to see an ob
gyn
you could see your family medicine
doctor because we're trained in
gynecology as well the time that i would
recommend that you go
is somewhere between the ages of 13 to
15 if you start having sex and you
become sexually active earlier in your
life than 13 to 15 which i don't
recommend but it can happen
you should go at that point and it
doesn't mean that you're going to get
any tests
it doesn't even mean that the doctor is
going gonna examine you it could just
mean that we can have a conversation
about things that you're doing
maybe some answer some questions that
you may have about your body starting
early can set a really good
routine for you that you'll fall into
without really worrying on whether or
not you need to see your doctor
or is it too late thomas sears i think
you're left-handed
maybe you're partially right thomas
because when i play baseball when i play
hockey when i try
golf very poorly i will always was a
lefty so stick sports
i am lefty but i wouldn't say i'm
left-handed because i write i eat and i
brush my teeth
all with my right hand sweetest thing
what are your thoughts
and or medical opinion on hookah and the
dangers of it
sweetest thing i've never smoked i've
never done drugs in my life my friends
always
sort of poke fun at me that i'm the
person that never tried these things
but i did try hookah and in fact when i
was growing up i had a hookah in my
house
because it was something that all my
friends loved doing and it was just
something that was around
i didn't really smoke it a lot i mean i
took like a pull here or there
i don't recommend it in fact when you
look at how long
most people smoke hookah meaning how
long they actually spend
inhaling and breathing the air back out
it's a long time and you still have the
harmful effects of tobacco
nicotine the carcinogens from the
burning of the tobacco going into your
lungs it's not benign
water vapor it's not completely innocent
like a lot of people say
you're actually burning the tobacco and
then that smoke goes through the water
and comes out i don't do it anymore
at all and i haven't done it in ages i
don't remember probably like 10 years
ago is the last time i did it hookah is
not safe
it's not something you should be doing
if you want to be healthy and happy and
play sports and be successful
just skip it flit deck hey dr mike do
you listen to your own heart with your
stethoscope out of curiosity or boredom
i wonder if i can get the mic to hear
this
nothing oh i tried letting you hear my
heart yeah i've listened to it before
i haven't done it in a really long time
because whenever i have this on i'm
working and i'm busy
in medical school especially i really
listen to my heart with dolly studios
love the content dr mike what advice
would you give
an artist engaging in a long-term
relationship with a doctor
biggest piece of advice i'll give you is
be patient
becoming a doctor is a stressful tedious
difficult but ultimately very rewarding
experience so the more patient you can
be with the person that you're in a
relationship with
the more open communication you can have
with that person the more successful
your relationship is going to be
i remember a lot of relationships ended
during medical school and that was
something my dad constantly told me he
noticed within his class
as well if you're meant for each other
you'll make it through it if not
great you learned something about
yourself and so did their so did your
partner
and you could take that on and find a
successful partner in the future
misophonia hearing recurrent sounds
bells song lyrics
and especially kids babbling complaining
crying drives me to pull out my hair
could you address this condition adam
i've never heard of it let me google it
right now actually let me check this out
a strong reaction to specific sounds
it's rare fewer than 200 000 cases per
year
usually self-diagnosable and it says
people may experience anger anxiety
uh they can even develop a fear of loud
sounds or
depression i've never heard about this
this is interesting i'm learning myself
this is why i love medicine we're always
learning
we're always trying to figure out how to
better serve our patients and that's why
i fell in love with the field
doing research being able to find
information very quickly
and specifically accurate quality
information is a hallmark
of the new modern age family physician
william cooper
hey dr mike can you help me get home
i'll gladly help you out brother but i
don't know what you're asking right now
do you know what he's asking i don't
know what he's saying
please make a video of you opening fan
mail karine i want to do that
i just opened my p.o box i haven't
checked it yet the address is actually
down below for the po box and all my
videos in the description so if you want
to send me something fun
please do and as soon as i get enough
stuff i'm gonna open it
on one video and we can talk about what
i'm getting just make sure if you're
sending something personal and you don't
want it to be in the video
make that very clear so i don't hurt
your privacy hey dr mike have you ever
had a patient that started out with the
idea that it could be a physical
diagnosis
but ended up being a mental diagnosis ps
love the channel
thanks nick and thank you for this
question because
something i've become incredibly
passionate about is
mind-body disorders and i know that
sounds a little bit like a frou-frou
diagnosis
it's not the mind and body are truly one
communication happens both ways
so if you do something that affects the
body it also affects the mind if you get
injured or like stab
yourself in the leg or get stabbed in
the leg your heart rate goes up if
something is going on in your mind
you're depressed you're anxious your
blood pressure also goes up the mistake
modern medicine makes is that there is
an assumption that
all medical issues come down to
a physical problem a physical root cause
and that's not the case in doing
research and in
reading quality books on the subject
what i found is
there are a ton of medical conditions
that are actually caused
by the mind-body connection instead of
just the physical cause that's why a big
part of this movement in modern medicine
is to
seek out mindfulness because mindfulness
doesn't just mean being in touch with
your breathing
yes that could be part of it but also it
means being in touch with your emotional
side of things
because emotions have an impact on your
physical body
that's that's been proven there are a
lot of patients that come in wanting a
physical diagnosis or believing they
have a physical diagnosis
and then they walk out with their
problem gone
with their uh cause of the problem
solved
not because i did something physical to
them like a shot injection or therapy
but just because we had a very good
conversation and they learned something
about themselves
from rummaging in the comments section
or running around the streets
i love answering your questions so
please keep them coming drop your
questions
and comments down below also very
important don't forget to hit subscribe
and hit that notification bell as always
stay happy and healthy
try mouth today i i said subject subject
ana miso
misophonia
i'm allergic to something and
[Music]
you